listen i was turning up to first class
while i was getting ready today you did
it again and the sampling fergie i mean
were you just listening to glamorous one
day and thought that would make a sick
sample i grew up loving fergie like she
literally inspired me
so
when i was in fifth grade i tried to
perform fergalicious at the talent show
i love i have like a strong artistic
connection to fergie
so i've been wanting to do that for a
while and it just came together and i
figured
it's time the world it would be
refreshing the world i'm curious
how many kids know that or if this is
their first you know because i was a kid
when i was out you know i respect you so
much for being a fergie stan i love it
but i gotta tell you people are loving
this line from the song i'm on angus
cloud nine did you talk to angus about
using his name in your song i didn't
even tell him i just wanted to surprise
him what was his reaction i ain't heard
yet i don't know i'm waiting to see you
big angus cloud fan or what i like angus
oh my god you know what you spit nothing
but fire the caption to my post today is
i didn't peek in high school i'm just
out here getting cuter i feel that i
believe it too you believe it yeah
all right so do you know that you are
the internet's boyfriend right now like
you're getting so much love from
everybody are you feeling it
i can feel the love
yeah
i uh yeah i feel the love you're so
humble and shy are the dms popping you
gotta let me know man you know everyone
wants to date you
yeah i don't check them that often i
check every once in a while are you
loving the single life right now
yeah there's some candidates i focus on
my career right now i'm hungry ambitious
yo they want me to get your reaction to
a couple of thirst comments on tick tock
do you want to read these out loud for
me
what's that first one right there
please i'd let you do anything to me sir
i thought this was a kid's choice awards
okay is this a kiss choice just two more
bro i could not believe this is on this
paper i don't mean either actually i'm
reading these for the first time too oh
no my back is arching okay now just read
the last one skip that one please
because that was just inappropriate bro
i cannot believe what i'm seeing on this
paper
where i'm at i literally walked in here
and switched gears like all right jack
you got to be his listen i'm a grown man
too last one right here
i don't drive a tesla but you can have
your feet out the window of my ford
focus okay that's appropriate the one
the one above it
yeah i don't even want to be the one
that said it no i didn't want you to do
it either insanity anyways have so much
fun in there tonight congrats on
everything nice to meet you
thank you so much